مره اخرى الى كيف ومراسله الجزيره حسان
مسعود لمواكبه اخر التطورات بعد هذا القصف
الصاروخي الجوي الذي تحدث عن القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وايضا الانفجارات التي
سمع عدويها في العاصمه الاوكرانيه حسان ما
الذي يجري الان
هجومنا مكثف تعرضت له العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف يعتبر هجوم غير مسبوق منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب نظرا لان اصوات الانفجارات دوت في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بعد دقائق قليله فقط
من سماعي ذوي سفارات الانذار خلال النهار
وشاهدنا خلال هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه انطلاق
مجموعه كبيره من الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه لاعتراض عددا من الصواريخ قبل
قليل كنا في منطقه تعتبر بالغه الحساسيه
ورصدنا كيف ان هذه المنشاه تعرضت
للاستهداف وليد دمار كبير منعنا من
التصوير وايضا سحبت من الماده المصوره
هناك نظرا لان المنطقه التي تعرضت
للاستهداف هي شديده الحساسيه لكننا الان
في احد المواقع ايضا الاخرى التي تعرضت
على ما يبدو لسقوط حطام لصواريخ هذه الصور
التي ستشاهدونها الان على هواء شاشه
الجزيره هي
بقايا حطام الصواريخ احد الصواريخ التي
اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
وتشاهدون كيف ان هذا الجزء من الصاروخ
الذي يبدو واضحا قد تعرض
لاستهداف وقد سقط على الارض هنا في هذا
المكان في المنطقه الواقعه وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
وقد
ادى هذا الى اضرار كبيره
في عدد من المواقع في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
نتيجه سقوط حطام الصواريخ وحده دون الحديث
ايضا عن الصواريخ التي ربما على ما يبدو
انها تمكنت من ان تصل الى المكان الذي
كانت تريد استهدافه
وادت الى الى اضرار بالغه في المبنى وايضا
ادت الى اضرار في المحيط هذا المبنى عندما
كنا نمر من ذاك المكان كانت ساعات او فرق
الدفاع الجوي تتعامل مع حرائق في المنطقه
التي استهدفت بهذه الصواريخ بهذا النوع من
الصواريخ الذي حتى هذه اللحظه لا نتمكن
ولا نستطيع من الحديث عن نوع الصاروخ بشكل
دقيق نظرا لان هذه الصواريخ
سقطت بشكل سريع للغايه هذا الحطام للصاروخ
الذي نشاهده الان هنا يبدو على الاقل انه
من بين انواع الصواريخ المجنحه ولكن ايضا
لا نستطيع ان نتحدث عن نوع الصاروخ بشكل
خاص قبل قليل المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
قال ان عدد من الصواريخ
انطلقت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعدد من
المناطق وان انفجارات دوت في مناطق مختلفه
كذلك ايضا عمده كييف اكد ان فرق الانقاذ
توجهت نحو عدد من المواقع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه عقب سماعي داوي انفجارات من
نتحدث